I tricked Sam bankman freed into a third
interview with me and this time he may
have admitted to fraud you'll be the
judge you can click to this timestamp if
you just want to listen to the interview
but I want to explain the background the
strategy that went into this call to try
to learn where others had failed
including by the way learning from my
own failures interviewing Sam now first
I want to give some background Sam at no
point has wanted to talk to me every
time I've kind of snuck on these q and
A's and started peppering them with
questions he usually leaves but I
realized that since this was my third
time basically doing the exact same
trick it was probably going to be one of
my last because at some point he was
going to catch on so I knew going into
this it might be my last chance to
interview Sam and because of that I had
to think long and hard about what the
perfect line of questioning would be to
really pin Sam down knowing that he's a
master at dodging questions he's done it
with everybody so far including me by
the way and I mean look I think we've
got some great stuff but to this point I
didn't think anyone had gotten that
Smoking Gun he always denies everything
he always has a sort of a loophole out
of it so I'd have to try a different
tactic and here was my plan Sam's whole
excuse about not being a con man all
hinges around Alameda research basically
he says he knew nothing of what was
going on there because he was just the
CEO of FTX and while that's nearly
impossible to believe that he's this
stupid or incompetent it's really hard
to prove a hundred percent so I realized
if we're gonna do this I'd have to
remove Alameda from my case right I need
it to show that Sam had knowingly
defrauded people without invoking
Alameda at any point and here was my
plan to do it I was going to spend the
entire time laser focused on the FTX
terms of service now some of you may
know FTX lays out that they cannot use
customer funds for anything they can't
trade with them they can't loan them out
and I thought this was a really
important point because obviously that
money is no longer there so clearly
something must have happened but I'm far
from the first person to notice this
many people including myself have
already tried to ask him about this and
pin him down but for various reasons
well it didn't work and I needed to
learn why so we could avoid it so I want
to go through a few major interviews
with Sam and show why this line of
questioning has always fallen apart
starting with the New York Times the
terms of service for FTX and I just want
to read you this it says None of the
digital Assets in your account
are the property of or shell or maybe
loan two FTX trading FTX trading does
not represent or treat digital assets
and users accounts as belonging to FTX
trading so how is it possible that
Alameda
had this loan of such a large size
so
there's that piece from the terms of
service
um but there were a number of other
parts of the terms as there's a number
of other parts of the platform on top of
that there is the borrow lending
facility where users were lending
billions of dollars of assets to each
other
um you know collateralized by assets on
the exchange
um you had uh and you got obviously
Futures contracts where there are
leveraged positions on now of course all
of this
um it's meant to be the case that these
are positions where fgx could uh if it
needed to Margin Call those positions
and close them down in times such that
it would cover all of those uh you know
all those shorts all those liabilities
obviously that wasn't the case here and
that's a massive failure of oversight of
risk management
um and of uh you know diffusion of
responsibility from from myself running
FTX
but just make this very straight was
there commingling of funds that's what
it appears like it appears like there's
a genuine commingling of the funds that
are of FTX customers that were not
supposed to be commingled with your
separate firm
I ain't knowing leeco mingle funds okay
Sorkin tried and failed here to pin him
down on the terms of service why well
because Sam Escapes in this talk about a
different part of the terms of service
which related to margin trading where
you take out some kind of a loan and in
a way it was a complete deflection like
it doesn't matter that there's a
separate margin trading in terms of
service because the people who weren't
margin Trading still should have had
their funds kept safe but it sort of
threw Sorkin off track and so now we're
going to move to the Stephanopoulos
interview which was a bit better because
Sam's going to try the margin trading
story but watch Stephanopoulos he does a
better job at honing in on the question
but as you know the FTX terms of service
tell the people who signed up none of
the digital Assets in your account are
the property of or shall be or may be
loaned to FTX Trading but you're saying
that happen my understanding is a few
things happen the first is there is a
margin trading facility on FTX by which
users can lend out funds by which other
users borrow funds and so there are
explicit cases where there is you know
marching extended where there is borrow
lending if the Alameda is borrowing the
money that belongs to FDX depositors
that's a bright red line isn't it there
are a lot of cases where that's actually
explicitly part of the programs and that
are happening here here it says that the
digital assets may not be loaned to FTX
Trading
they can't be loaned out
I
there existed a bar lending facility on
FTX and I think that's probably covered
I don't remember exactly where but
somewhere else in the terms of service
but they'd have to approve of that
they're saying they didn't approve of it
here they're saying you approved of it
now this is great stuff from
Stephanopoulos he refocused the question
but Sam's about to weasel out with the
new trick go ahead and watch if you've
rewinded to you know the beginning of
FTX
um where
you know some customers were you know uh
I think in line with sort of existing
relationships that they've had at least
in some cases wiring money straight to
Alameda research in order to trade on
FTX so you do know and you did know that
FDX deposits were being funneled to
Alameda so I was vaguely aware that that
was how some virus were being sent in
the first place
um didn't that set off alarm bells in
your head so there are a lot of people
who are involved in that process and
look I really deeply wish that I had
taken like a lot more responsibility for
understanding
what the details were of what was going
on there
this is how he slips out again he tried
the margin trading explanation it didn't
work so he pivots to okay well there's
this weird backstory where FTX used to
take wires from Alameda and maybe that's
where we lost the money right it's
another smoke screen but unfortunately
it kind of hamstrung the conversation
and if I was going to succeed I'd have
to beat that explanation and in the
first couple interviews I did with Sam I
tried to go with like this Insider angle
where insiders I had talked to had told
me something very different but it
didn't work go ahead and watch there's
sort of all this talk about the terms of
service did you break terms of service
did you not you're basically claiming
that there was a separate side of your
terms of service but I talked to
somebody from Alameda and asked how big
the position of like or how many people
had assets in the type of accounts that
that terms of service would apply to
versus the regular terms of service
which said you couldn't use their money
and they said it was about a billion
that was in the margin trading or the
the margin like uh
side of things where you could reuse
their funds or whatever and there was
the rest of it was not there so it seems
like you're putting all your eggs behind
this one excuse about you know there was
this separate side of the terms of
service how do you address everyone else
Sue I don't have all the day in front of
me my memory is that it was
substantially more than a billion I
can't verify that
um on top of that there were other
effects as well some of those were early
uh wire transfers sent directly to
Alameda
yeah I kind of got stuck where
Stephanopoulos roughly got stuck I I
should have known that he was just going
to refuse the evidence of insiders and
just say why disagree and go back to his
Alameda wire explanation and I tried
following it up a bit but it didn't
really matter I had kind of missed my
shot on that particular angle and as I
reflected on this I realized all of the
talk about margin trading future trading
why are transfers to Alameda all of it
is a smoke screen from the big problem
the big problem is that some percentage
of ftx's customer base never sent a
wired Alameda they never signed up to
margin trading they never did spot
margin all they did was put their assets
on the platform and they were told that
their assets would not be borrowed it
would not be loaned out and that money
would always be there and it wasn't
there why wasn't it there there's no
other way to explain that if the money's
not there then fraud and I had to laser
in on that one point not get distracted
by these shiny objects that Sam's
throwing up about this or that or what
about this what about that no there's
only one question that matters and it's
impossible for him to answer I thought
so that was my strategy going into it
that was the back story and how I
learned from previous interviews so
without further Ado here's my third and
probably Final Call with Sam bankman
freed
if you're trying to do things with good
intentions I'm about to go up
hey Sam it's me again I just wanted to
ask real quick about the terms of
service question which wrecked brought
up a little bit I want to expound on it
can you just tell us yes or no were you
treating client assets just on the
regular digital asset side different
from the margin trading side
uh I do think we're treating them
differently
um there were there were a bunch of
different sides there are more than two
sides there
um but I do think that we that we I that
we work cognizant of the fact that like
there were differences between uh uses
for for like you know margin versus
staking versus uh spot versus Futures
collateral uh versus other things yeah
just people I'm just talking about
people just you know putting Bitcoin on
the exchange obviously there was really
clear uh terms of service around that
if it's true that you didn't invest
client assets not even in treasuries as
you said via a now deleted tweet why do
those client assets no longer exist
so
I'm trying to trace through some of this
here's my best guess and and I wish I
could give you more confident answer but
I don't have the data
um but my best guess is basically it's a
combination of the following
um one piece is uh the transfer sent
directly to uh uh directly to Alameda
research
um uh from customers uh one piece and
that I think is a is a I think a fairly
substantial piece
um uh one piece
is wait can you explain what that piece
means so people were sending money to
Alameda instead of either getting
credited on FTX and Alameda just ended
up using those funds and they were never
held held separately per the terms of
service
well there was a separate legal
agreement with that I don't know the
details of it I don't have it in front
of me but there's separate legal
agreement with respect to transfers that
were sent directly to Alameda research
uh by users um especially before
um FTX had
um its own bank accounts
um and so I do think that that is part
of what happened there likely let's
focus on let's focus on only client
assets that happened after FTX got a
bank y'all said digital assets are
treated a very specific way why were
those digital assets not treated that
way
so after so of of the ramp meaning a
piece and there there's a few other
pieces as well um around features and
other things I understand that's not
what you're talking about
um for the ones that you are talking
about right for the ones that were left
and I'm again I'm I'm I'm just taking a
stab at this because I don't have the
data but my my best guess is the
following is that there were a lot of
those assets remaining
um we processed something like
um you know five or six billion dollars
I think of withdrawals
um over the uh you know over the few
days
um prior to or I guess a few days you
know during the crash and
um there are still a few billion dollars
of those remaining I think in the estate
um and so you put those together you
have many billions of dollars of those
assets
um but I think and and so that's part of
the answer is that
um there were a large number of actual
assets there
um
I I think there's one follow-up question
you probably still have there which is
well how about people who didn't
withdraw and were also in that bucket
and part of the answer is well there
still do exist some number of billions
of dollars of assets of hard assets no
is there one-to-one assets because
that's the whole thing we're talking
about a separation of funds so those
funds should be a completely different
in a different place and a different
wallet than everybody else what you
talked about servicing billions of
dollars of withdrawals has nothing to do
with those specific digital assets
because that's just first come first
serve whoever pulled out first we're
talking about people who never agreed to
have their funds loaned out who never
agreed to have their funds put on margin
they should have according to your terms
of service one-to-one backing it should
all still be in some bucket somewhere
and are you confident today as the CEO
of FTX this has nothing to do with
Alameda are you confident today to say
that you those are absolutely real and
they exist and they're present people
are backed one to one on client digital
assets so I think and again this is I'm
just taking a stab here but I think what
happened
um is that if you look at especially a
lot of the withdrawals that happened
um those withdrawals were not
necessarily only coming from people who
never used margin trading or futures or
staking or anything else those weren't
just withdrawals from people who were
um uh who were keeping one-to-one backed
or or or were you know we're sort of you
know just keeping them as pure spot
balances
um and it was Omnibus wallets you know
between the various categories
um and so I think that the answer to
your question is that
um uh is that a number of those assets
um were withdrawn by people who had
balances on the exchange
um potentially in the few days prior to
the collapse
um and uh and you know if you wanted to
think about it this way it could be that
you know that happened and then
um you know when
when the collapse sort of completed uh
the
um
that that effectively meant that there
was you know if you wanted to put it
this way like uh fungibility created
during those withdrawals between assets
uh for people who had and had not uh
been using anything but that means that
there is no separation of fund if
there's fungibility between two
different buckets of God there are no
buckets it's just one bucket everyone's
taking out of the bucket which means
substantially anyone who had your terms
of service with digital assets wasn't
actually subject to that terms of
service they were subject to the same
terms of service of your margin trading
right which is your more risky product
so you subjected everyone to the higher
risk product because fundamentally when
it came down to it you're saying there's
fungibility it's a dollar here a dollar
there everyone can take out a dollar as
fast as they want
don't you see that as like defrauding
your customers the people who trusted
you to just say hey this is not going to
go anywhere except for we're not
investing your assets if it if I can
exchange one to one and I'm the one who
put risky stuff on on with risky um
assets with risky terms of service I can
take the money that someone who didn't
sign up to those same risky terms didn't
agree to isn't that fraud
so
I'm specifically talking about what
happened
unit the days immediately
um during and following the crash in
that you know three or say so day period
um and during that period
um I think we may have allowed uh you
know just generalized withdrawals I
think that was
um you know if you're saying that we
should have held up withdrawals for
everyone who had an open Futures
position
um you know for clawback potential or
something like that uh I don't know
maybe that would have been the right
thing to do I hear where you're coming
from on that
um I felt you know at the time
um that you know we wanted to treat
customers equally and it was an
incredible but they had agreed to
different things so you can't treat them
equally I mean it's like this is the
whole problem of the story of FTX and
Alameda is all the funds were being
co-mingled isn't this just another story
of co-mingling funds except this is now
FTX which you can't pass the blame to
Alameda anymore this is your company
your funds that you are treating all the
clients the same when they clearly
signed up to different terms of service
so I I just want to respond to that and
please I completely respect your
question but you have monopolized all of
these discussions coffee Zilla you need
to let others speak and you need to
respond to what I am saying and not
grandstand as much here I completely
understand where you're coming from but
the
to answer your question
I didn't make a decision there I just we
process withdrawals as we normally do
until it became clear we couldn't
anymore at which point we shut them off
and it was the case that like at that
point
um there was a big liquidity hole
that's what happened if you want to
judge that process and think that like
we should have been spending those days
frantically trying to code up a new
withdrawal process
um I disagree with you but I understand
where you're coming from
yeah sure I think that's uh fine I mean
it's not about coding up a new
withdrawal process it's about treating
your client assets the way you told them
they'd be treated right it's a very
different thing
uh completely but anyways I'll stop a
grandstanding for Sam thanks guys
ha
whoa
[Applause]
oh my gosh wow we got the call out we
got we got the shout out all right you
can probably tell I was I was pretty
excited about that because I finally got
what I was looking for a straight answer
on the problem of funds right Sam
explicitly says that FTX was not
separating funds they were allowing
generalized withdrawals the dollars were
fungible from different buckets you
can't do that we finally dodged all the
BS about margin trading about Alameda
wires we finally got to the heart of it
which is that there are no funds left
over for the people who just had should
have had their fun separated because
they never separated them from the
beginning they were always seemingly
co-mingled and although Sam wouldn't
necessarily agree that they were always
co-mingled the proof is in the pudding
FTX owes billions of dollars that they
do not have and it's because of how they
allowed withdrawals to give you kind of
a regular Finance analogy about why the
this is so cataclysmically bad and in my
opinion fraud imagine you banked at
JPMorgan Chase right and you have your
money in the savings account part
well then you find out that they
actually had this risky hedge fund and
you know what they actually kind of blew
up in fact they blew up so badly that
JPMorgan Chase it's all shutting down
but when you go to the bank to withdraw
your money you find out that instead of
keeping your money safely in your
savings account they had allowed the
people in the hedge fund business to
just withdraw it you know first come
first serve right they treated all
clients the same according to them well
you say well no that's fraud because you
signed up to very different terms of
service than the guy who knew he was
going to be like you know in this hedge
fund right he had a different level of
risk he acknowledged that level of risk
and if you just throw all the money in
one pot the terms of service are
meaningless right you're exposed to the
same level of risk as the guy who took
on huge risk and that's fundamentally
what happened at FTX that's fraud they
told people their money was safe and
ultimately they just subjected everyone
to the same risk as like the day trading
degenerate Gambler on 100x Leverage and
I really found the last thing Sam told
me like so telling to answer your
question
I didn't make a decision there I just we
process withdrawals as we normally do
that's what happened if you want to
judge that process and think that like
we should have been spending those days
frantically trying to code up a new
withdrawal process
um I disagree with you but I understand
where you're coming from this is so
interesting because no of course I don't
think you should be coding up a new
withdrawal process while you're going
bankrupt but if throwing all your client
funds in a pool and letting the first
come first serve get the money that's
the wrong process to begin with your
process was fraudulent from the start it
should have never been your process your
process should have been what you
promised clients which is of course what
I told Sam and although I think Sam's
probably guilty of a lot more than we
covered here I really wanted to get to
this minimum viable fraud case and I
think we did get it I mean there is no
sort of wiggling around the fact that he
was the CEO of FTX and all of this stuff
that was bad that we proved happened at
FTX you don't have to invoke Alameda to
get to this so you you can't say he
didn't know because he definitely did
know and he says he knew so the last
thing I'm going to close on and I think
I thought it was the funniest part was
his little Outburst at the end about me
monopolizing his time so I just want to
respond to that and please I completely
respect your question but you have
monopolized all of these discussions
coffee Zilla you need to let others
speak and you need to respond to what I
am saying and not grandstand as much
here and I thought it was notable for
two reasons one he hasn't lost his cool
once in any interview this is the first
time I heard him like really crack and I
thought that was interesting but I also
thought it was interesting because it's
just not true it's totally wrong I've
talked to Sam for I think 30 minutes
across three interviews total like in
total and for context he gave the New
York Times an hour he gave George
Stephanopoulos two hours I think out of
everyone he's talked to or at least of
the major interviews I've talked to him
the least so if anything I'm efficient
with my type that's all I'm going to say
and speaking of being efficient with my
time this video is over lock this man up
and I'll see you later thanks for
watching